-Welcome back, everybody.
We're talking to Bad Bunny!
Now, you're --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're releasing music maybe,
you're going on tour definitely,
and now you're making
your acting debut
in "Narcos: Mexico."
I mean --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're used to performing.
You've done almost everything.
How different was this?
-It's different, but at the same
time, it's the same, you know?
You have to work hard
to be responsible
and, you know,
respect the colleagues.
-Yeah, of course.
-I enjoy.
You know,
it's something new for me,
but I like it, and I enjoy it.
I'm learning and practicing.
I keep practicing, you know?
-Did you go to them,
or did they come to you?
-They come to me.
-Of course.
As I figured, yeah.
But I don't know
if you were a fan of --
I mean, if you're a fan of --
'Cause I love "Narcos."
I've seen it, I go --
-No, me too.
Me too.
-Can you set up your character
and who you play?
-My character is Benito --
I'm Kitty Páez.
Kitty Páez.
-Kitty?
-Kitty.
-Yep.
-Kitty Páez.
-Gotta love it, man.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's good.
-Yeah, he's a member of the
Arellano-Félix organization.
They have the cartel in Tijuana.
-Yeah.
-And he's one of the --
-He's one of the new young kids
that are like --
-Yeah.
-Not old school.
Like, you guys are, like,
going to clubs and stuff
and doing stuff
you shouldn't be doing.
-He's part of the -- one of the
Narco Juniors, the young guys.
-Also, you're such a nice,
positive guy.
Is it tough to act
and be this mean?
-I'm a good guy.
-You're a Bad Bunny,
but you're a good man,
yeah, absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
-But it was fun.
You know, it was fun.
And the character is, like,
a cool guy, young guy.
I'm a cool guy, I think so,
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-You're one of the coolest, man.
I just love that you did it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Bad Bunny
in "Narcos: Mexico" this Friday.
Take a look.
[ Conversing in Spanish ]
-That's my man, Bad Bunny!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The third season
of "Narcos: Mexico"
begins streaming this Friday
on Netflix!